the federal government starts rolling
back net neutrality rules today the
republican-led Federal Communications
Commission voted to repeal the Obama era
regulations in December
now those rules required online service
providers to treat all Internet traffic
the same without slowing down or
blocking content from competing
providers FCC Chairman a GP I wrote for
our partners at seen it overnight the
Internet should be an open platform
where you are free to go where you want
and say what you do say and do what you
want without having to ask anyone's
permission first on CBS this morning
chairman PI is here to discuss what this
means for consumers good morning good
morning to you thanks for having me
first let me give you the opportunity to
explain why are you rolling back these
Obama era regulations to us the Internet
is one of the greatest innovations in
history it's allowed consumers to do
things so that were unimaginable a
generation ago and that's thanks in part
to President Clinton's decision in 1996
to adopt a more market-based approach we
weren't going to regulate this new thing
called the Internet like a slow-moving
utility your water company or Electric
Company and the like those that
light-touch approach produce incredible
benefits for consumers that is the
framework to which we are returned so
you believe the internet should be
completely unregulated no not at all
that's why at the FCC we have a very
robust transparency will rule and we've
empowered the Federal Trade Commission
to take targeted action against any bad
apple in the internet economy that harms
consumers these rules were put in place
to prevent internet providers from
blocking speeding up or slowing down
access the idea was that a company could
say like AT&T you know what I've got to
deal with Netflix so you know what I'm
gonna slow down Hulu yes could that
could they do that now that you've
repealed this law two different points
so prior to 2015 when these regulations
were imposed during the Obama
administration we did not see that our
gated actions like that against Internet
traffic secondly going forward we have
empowered the Federal Trade Commission
to take action against any company
including those that in this situation
that you mentioned that might acted in
any competitive way so consumer is going
to be protected and we preserve the
incentive for companies to build out
better faster cheaper internet access
for consumers across the country you say
that we hadn't seen that before but in
fact in 2007 Comcast did just what the
credit
have worried about and AT&T did it as
well pardon me so in the past exactly
what critics say might happen was
happening so that's not the case what
you said in the first incidents for
example the latter situation was
resolved without these net neutrality
regulations that was resolved before
these regulations were in place in the
second one the Federal Trade Commission
actually took action almost a year
before the FCC did to take action
against that throttle in case but the
point is that the instinct is there
within the companies it was alive
beforehand but you're saying well now
look before hand because the instinct
wasn't there the instinct is there for
these companies to do that and you're no
incentive right the financial incentive
isn't there so now they know basically
they can do what they want and it's up
to the consumers to try to police them
that's not true so again both at the FCC
we have a transparency rule where every
company in the United States has to
disclose their business practices and
the Federal Trade Commission is
empowered to take action against any
company who engages in any
anti-competitive conduct we've seen with
companies like Facebook they say well we
show you that your privacy settings can
be found over here one of the things
that the Senate has said is you know
it's very hard to find where the rules
are so this transparency people say sure
they might somewhere disclosed but
they're blocking but it'll be impossible
for people in your example is a perfect
incidence of why the Federal Trade
Commission needs to take action the FCC
does not have jurisdiction over
companies like Facebook and Google only
the Federal Trade Commission can apply a
consistent level of privacy protection
for consumers across the internet
economy whether you're a Comcast and
AT&T or a Google or Facebook consumers
need to be protected and the Federal
Trade Commission is the only one under
current law that can do that so starting
today why do you think it's gonna be
better for consumers and how is it going
to be better for consumers it's going to
be a tremendously positive thing for
consumers when I talk to consumers and
I've been to everywhere from Los Angeles
to the rosebud Sioux Reservation in
South Dakota to Dahlonega Georgia a few
weeks ago their number one concern about
the internet is that where they want
better faster cheaper Internet access
more competition these rules were
standing in the way of companies big and
small making the decision to spend money
building these networks in billions
networks is hard it's expensive the
heavier the regulatory burden the less
likely they are to do it and so going
forward we've already heard from some
companies companies like v-tail in
Vermont that are spending millions of
dollars to upgrade their network
especially in rural areas to get people
connected with what I call digital
opportunity to John's point it does seem
like it opens the door now for companies
to do exactly what you don't want them
to do again President Clinton's
framework heard as well from 96 until
2015 i'm confident going forward we'll
have cops on the beat at the FCC and FTC
you prevent that from happen last week
tonight host john oliver urged his
viewers to flood the FCC lines in part
because he supports neutrality
regulations let's take a look the
websites your websites comment section
was taken offline which I know the FCC
has claimed that was because of a cyber
attack your critics say the FCC is lying
can you respond to that again we rely on
our career information technology
experts as I've done for the years and I
think they made the decision that they
thought was appropriate based on the
facts was it just that the web that that
was actually overwhelmed by the traffic
again here too I rely on the career IT
experts to advise us okay
IG thanks so much for being with us